[MUSIC PLAYING]
As a mobile developer,
keeping up to date
with the latest
products and trends
is crucial to running
a successful business.
So we made an app to let you
in on the secrets to success.
With the Playbook
app by Google Play,
you can discover the features,
best practices, and tips
to making your products
more successful.
Choose topics relating
to your app and your role
to get tailored news and tips.
Browse curated
articles and videos
from Google and
across the industry.
Swipe across an
article to take action.
And explore the in-depth guide
to Google's developer products.
Get the Playbook app
today on Google Play.